hey guys good Morgan hi okay so like so
many fans out there I had been waiting
very patiently for a sequel to the
kissing booth and it did not disappoint
I loved it so much honestly so so good
Joey what were you looking forward to
most when it came to you know getting
back to the cast and and coming on board
for kissing booth - oh my goodness
well I was just looking forward to
seeing all my friends again all my South
African friends where we shot the
kissing booth in South Africa I just
love those guys so much and so being
able to see them again perform with them
again come back and just like hug them
all again it was amazing and honestly
just really look forward to being back
with this guy right here I mean we have
so much fun together and I know that
Ellen Lee like they are always they have
such a huge place in both of our hearts
and so whenever we get together and
those characters are present it's just a
guaranteed good time yeah you guys have
such great BFF chemistry Joel what's it
like working with Joey on set just the
worst
she's man being she controlled he
directs me yeah Joey is an angel she is
so playful and fun it's it's funny
earlier she called me like the brother
that she never had and I've like
referenced her as like a younger sister
to me like we have that natural like
friendship and sibling relationship and
it's really well of these two characters
and I honestly can't imagine doing this
movie with anyone else and I wouldn't
want to it is just so much fun and that
is actually the thing that I was most
looking forward to coming back into a
sequel was getting to do LM Lea scenes
again oh so the chemistry we see is real
100% right Joel and I have developed
such a close friendship over the over
the years and I just from the first
movie all we have done is gotten closer
yeah okay so in the first movie you guys
showed off some pretty good dance moves
but in the sequel you take those dance
moves to the next level I mean how much
practice went into perfecting those
dance dance moves
so hey for a few weeks before the movie
we we were incessant we we wanted the
moves to be perfect and we put in the
work yeah and then during filming - we
had so much for her so time it was
really like a never-ending like
rehearsal like we always were dancing I
was like I'm sweating so much I was
eating so much because I was just
sweating all day long all the afford you
just have like two burgers a day if I
design yeah it was one of those things
that was I was like I would cook in my
my apartment that are staying at and I
would like tap out the dance moves like
in like the back of my head and I was
like that's amazing
okay so Ellen Leigh follow a set of
rules when it comes to their friendship
so if you depict one rule to be the best
friends you know possible what one rule
would you follow I think Jill and I have
settled on rule number 18 it's always be
happy for your besties it's honestly
it's either life just just be happy for
people in their successes and celebrate
with them okay so being that this movie
obviously focuses on a kissing booth you
had to pick a celebrity to share a
kissing booth with who would you pick
Joey got Benedict Cumberbatch oh that's
a good one right like what it what it
hottie like come on dreamboat yeah his
only has only aged better just fine
every moment that he exists and is alive
it's just better yep and then if you can
speak to you and the kissing booth even
better that voice get out of here right
because every time I think of the
kissing booth it's with my fiancee oh
that's a good answer
that's a good fiancee the safe answer
because she's gonna see this right no no
that's good okay so then let me ask
you congratulations by the way on your
recent engagement um are you in select
wedding plans right now are you guys
keeping it low right now or deep in the
wedding plans we are pulling together
the party of the century
yeah yeah I'm confident saying I'm
really looking forward to it and there's
this all there's a lot it's more than
you ever would imagine before planning
right it's crazy but yeah me is really
great with like aesthetic and she's got
a great eye for design and it's the the
best day oh okay well guys I ran out of
time but thank you so much for your time
and I love the sequel I think fans are
just gonna lose it but you love them
Thank You Morgan
yeah see you guys later